the packers sixth straight victory over
the bears they're 6-0 at home this
season they can clinch the nfc north
next week for chicago their seventh loss
in their last eight games but they
certainly had some highlights in this
one and the guys who saw it firsthand
jack and rodney from lambeau field and
chris thought that you guys at least
rodney is too bundled up for what the
weather is at lambeau field here today
guys
i don't know what the temperature is it
feels like
hey chris sims i'm a little darker than
you okay so brothers get a little cold
okay that's all i'm saying it's about 15
degrees difference between me and you
what took it over the top was you
wearing snow pants that was the first
time i've seen somebody on tv wearing
snow pants so i love it though you the
man hey hey
i got so many hand warmers stuck to my
shoes i'm walking on sunshine around
here it's unbelievable they said it was
cold i've been sweating the entire game
let's get into this game though real
quick rod it was a slow start at the
beginning it still looked like the
packers were partying away the bye week
what'd you think of aaron rodgers his
response after that i have a lot of
respect for aaron rodgers and what he
brings i mean if anybody ever had a toe
a sore toe or even turf toe you
understand how difficult it is to be out
here not only just out here but in these
frigid temperatures the guy has i just
have so much respect for him because
he's so tough and you see without aaron
rodgers i don't know where this team
would be without him and devonta adams
he had his hands full there for a little
bit with that match-up on the outside
before the floodgates opened what
happened after that i thought jalen
johnson did an excellent job probably
one of the best jobs that a quarterback
has done on
devontae adams but the adjustment the
packers made they put him in the slot
and then that's when everything just
started taking off he scored a big
touchdown and he had a bunch of
different you know big catches chris
sims what did you see from this green
bay passing attack once it finally took
liftoff well i think rodney hits it i
mean first off they never totally
abandoned the run game right so that's
the one thing they always got for their
offense on that side of the ball but
then i think specifically to rogers and
rodney makes the point they move devonte
adams around to where you're not just
going to get a free pass and go oh
you're going to put them outside here
we're going to put our best corner on
you have to go somewhere else no they're
going to find ways to get the ball to
adams and then within that they're going
to make the defense defend him in the
new spots he's in whether you got to
double cover him change your game plan
and then that can open up you know other
receivers within the offense but you
know rogers to me right now and i would
put him in the discussion right at the
top with brady as far as mvp just has a
great feel of judging the game overall
you know he kind of lets it plays out he
gets a feel oh wait we're down by ten
okay now i'll step on the gas pedal
start taking some chances be aggressive
throwing the football but his connection
i think to to allude to what rodney's
saying with devonte adams i don't know
if there's a better connection in the
nfl as far as just
one guy
getting it to the other guy
every week and then of course them
coming up with plays to put him in good
situations as well
that's right it's telepathic
communication that those two have
between a rod and davonte adams that
friendship i think plays into that as
well it's pretty amazing though to watch
the start of the second half when they
went to that power running game right
row when they came out it's aj dillon
right down the field and i'm going get
him out get one of the best running
backs in the league and jones into the
game to go finish it off they did just
that why was that the perfect adjustment
coming out in the second half i thought
aj dillon we talked about in the
pre-game show i thought matt lafleur
does a really good job of rotating these
guys and not really just allowing these
guys to get tired or anything like that
and they're healthy so when you look at
aj dillon man he's big he's physical who
wants to hit a 250 pound back in these
frigid temperatures i'll tell you it's
tough man and we talked about in the
pre-game show also him taking that
physicality to the next level and he
showed it tonight that boy was running
did you see a world where they could get
both of those guys on the field at the
exact same time i was begging for you
put aaron jones in the slot he's another
playmaker i don't care if he's a running
back he's a playmaker put aj dylan in
the back those are headaches for the
defense chris james what do you think
about that getting a boat in the game
collectively and having the ability to
use him there in the slot talking about
aaron jones i would love that i think i
think it's a phenomenal idea it's a
little bit like what the 49ers do
already right i mean you see them use
two running backs on the field maybe
deebo samuel's at receiver all of a
sudden he's at tailback they move jeff
wilson to a slot receiver and he's lead
blocking for demo samuel on a toss sweep
or whatever but to me rodney makes a
good point again jones is very versatile
he's a big playback he catch the ball
out of the backfield he catches a you
know a crack in the seam and he can run
for a 70-yard touchdown now he's not
necessarily going to get you the tough
yards and i think that's what rodney's
talking about with aj dylan that's great
is when nothing's there aj dylan can
still smash it up in there and still get
four or five yards when the defense
actually wins the play but more weapons
on the field for a green bay offense
that i still think lacks big time
weapons they execute they don't waste
plays on the offensive side of the ball
but man aaron jones is kind of that
versatile guy rodney to your point that
could play slot receiver running back
you don't know what to expect
he'll be able to block a little bit for
aj dylan in the run game or vice versa i
would like to see it and i would think
it's something they would toy around
with as the season goes on they usually
steal a few plays from shanahan and the
49ers i wouldn't be shocked if you see
that come about at some point
those are the facts right there chris
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports